sie wären heute geimpft was bedeutet das
für sie ich will meinen verrühren
patienten mit gutem beispiel voraus
gehen dass er keine angst vor dieser
impfung habe in der zeitung eventuell
lesen der zeitung hat sich impfen lassen
dann wird schon ein solches kann sein
denn viele fürchten sich vor der impfung
was geht ihnen jetzt aber durch den kopf
ist es für sie ist was bedeutet dieser
tag ist ganz persönlicher für sie was
mir durch den kopf geht ich denke wenn
ich jetzt danke impft bin kann ich viel
leichter kontakt zu meiner familie haben
und ich hoffe dass ich dann ein
ungefährdeter mensch bin wenn ich fit
bin